[Music]
Captain Torrance flight Commander how
can I help you fugitive extradition
[Music]
oh is he dangerous what did he do
homicide 15 years ago I don't want to
scare the rest of the passengers I'm
afraid you're stuck with this Captain
get him on board let's have a good
flight
I'm cutting right through the top of the
storm
that's to keep everybody in their seats
no exceptions all right
[Music]
look at that
then we're done somewhere in the Jolo
Island cluster
it's run by separatists and militias the
Filipino Army won't even go there
anymore
the clock is ticking every minute
matters
we can count those minutes in lives lost
or saved
listen carefully this is an emergency
I'm captain Brody Torrance
I like this guy
Maxwell Carver England
[Music]
my passengers my responsibility I'm
gonna need your help I'm gonna need this
form a military or something see that
so why'd they lock you up no one cares
what really happened but they say
redemption can be found in the most
unusual places
you'll probably never see your family
again how about their families
I have a daughter and I have every
intention of making a home
they are going to come at us with
everything they've got
we're getting off this island
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]